this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block pizza in Los
Angeles
18:11 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach gray block a snazzy place to take
your face and get fully Italian open
your mouth feel the fire and the fun
it's Pizza gray block get that hitter
don't be alarmed that's not a fire
that's an alert the legend collection
has dropped and when I say dropped it's
landed right on my head
this right here is that hood hat it says
Philadelphia South Philly hood hat has
some killer hats for everyone out there
football fans and fans of other sports
you want the South Philly for your
Philadelphia Eagles fans you got that
hat you want that South Loop for the
Chicago Bears fans get it Chicago colors
South Loop we got Jordan hair for Auburn
Tigers we got Austin Texas for you Texas
fans and go on and hook that bestseller
they also have hats for baseball teams
with the baseball playoffs coming up you
can get Grand Concourse for the Yankees
Chavez Ravine for you Dodgers fans and
many others quick get in a hat that just
says Oh Philadelphia Eagles get a hat
that represents your hood check them out
you can go to at hood Hat USA on
Instagram or visit hood Hat calm and use
promo code hood USA for 20% off that's
promo code hood USA for 20% off hood Hat
calm get that ha ha do you suffer from
diabetes or arrhythmia or genetic
dysfunction in your body of your dick
well that can all change I have a
product right here called the ridge
wallet you tired of carrying a wallet in
the back ear pants like some creep like
some weirdo oh who's that in the
distance there with that big old you
know that big old leprosy bump on the
back of his in his pocket
oh that's just that crazy man and that's
a wallet well change that up don't be a
back pocket
wallet weirdo get that front pocket
hitter the new Ridge wallet the ridge
wallet is a special here this possibly
bulletproof establishment it's that
front pocket carry so suddenly quit
carrying around them condoms and the
extra you know receipts and all that
throw all that junk away get your
license get your ID give what you need
put it in the front pocket carry all
your credit cards look right there for
your cash and stay classy front pocket
carry go to Ridge wallet calm slash theö
and use code Theo at checkout for 10%
off that's code Theo for 10% off at
Ridge wallet comm slash Theo
they're good wallets today's guest is
from an underworld if you will in
America our one that's hidden she is a
sex worker we've been trying to get
someone from her universe up here into
ours for a while now if you're watching
on YouTube you'll know that she is
you'll notice that she's wearing a
disguise you know that facial kind of
you know a little bit of
hide-and-go-seek around the face and
neck and and but we're here to get into
her world today and we're so happy to
have her it is sex worker Allison
[Music]
good yeah you feel honestly like if I
you seem like someone who could be
anything to me you seem like anybody
from honestly vanilla ice right now to
Sinead O'Connor to someone at City of
Hope who has a cancer issue but also
somebody at who's maybe also at Barry's
boot camp so I feel like you are a wide
range killer sorry but I do feel like
you have a wide range going on right now
yeah she's here and she's in I don't
know if I'd call this disguise but we
have a sex worker with us today and her
name is Allison hello hello hi thanks
for coming in thanks for having me
are you nervous um slightly but I think
it's gonna be more fun than anything
okay yeah I think I'm good good now
enough if I say like you know recently
they've had and one of the reasons that
why I wanted to have you in or someone
in your line of work is because recently
they had can you bring it up Nick the
cesta a cesta is that right uh foster
foster cesta was what was passed through
the house and then FASTA is the bill
that was um
Sam was passed into law and signed by
the president
okay so I do actually have a couple um
like data about that as well so I can I
don't know if you want to talk about now
or like if you wanted to get into the
heavy stuff now or I have fun and then
get into the heavy stuff because it's
like kind of depressing okay no no well
I mean I guess now I almost feel like a
little bit of like a client now it's
like do I want to have fun and I can get
into the heavy stuff or do I want to get
into the heavy stuff and then have fun
well how about this how often do you
work um I work well it's varied over my
you know career but
I work anywhere between once a week to
three to four times a week well you say
times is that a full day or is okay the
most I'll see in one day is I mean
absolute max three clients and I really
don't that's like pushing it for me so
most the time I just see one or two okay
and when you say see a client is that
you're going over to their place or they
are how does that kind of work um it
depends like most the time if I'm going
out it's going to be meeting at a hotel
hmm and then I also have a location that
they can come to see me um that's very
obviously it needs to be discreet and
it's way more discreet than a hotel in a
lot of cases so um
and that's not like a van or something
like that I go no but it says uh not
like a storage shed no it's a very it's
a nice condo actually okay that I share
with a colleague okay yes and and so a
visit right like what are your clientele
like because when I think of somebody
that that hires a sex worker I mean I or
maybe not when I think of it when people
think of it I imagine they think of like
you know some guy and he's got you know
uh and easiest cheeks are all red kind
of like a young young Santa you know but
never got into doing gifts and like he's
you know he's you know and he's smoking
cigars and he's you know lying to his
wife and running around is that what is
a clientele what does the sex workers
clientele mine it's been very surprising
actually like and I have to say the
longer I've been doing it um
the better my clients have been uh you
know I at the beginning I still didn't
have like a lot of savings so I was kind
of just taking what I could get and at
this point I'm so opposite of that like
I'm so picky about who I see and you
know my interaction with them before I
see them a lot of my clients are man
they they really
very I've seen a lot of people that are
younger than me I that you know are
virgins
that's been a little weird yes I've had
a couple people pay me to take their
virginity because it was so awkward for
them to try and do that in their real
you know they're just like kind of nerdy
like they were in you know their second
or third year of college or whatever and
they just like couldn't um engage with a
girl in the real world so I could
imagine that I did have one like not
tell me and like in the middle of the
appointment I was like have you ever
done this before like it just kind of
clicked with me and I was like this dude
does not know what he's doing and then I
was like why didn't you tell me before
like that's kind of important
information but and then so I have
people like that and then yeah like how
did you know like was he doing it
backwards herself or like was there
seemed man it was just waiting to come
first and then no it was just really
awkward like the hip movements that were
happening and like just a lot of things
that were happening made me kind of
clued me in that I was like do in the
Carlton or something like I'm trying to
like this is a while ago so I'm and I
probably a lot of this stuff too I've
kind of just like you know washed my
memory oh it's okay I don't need to like
keep rehashing that in my mind but do
you have a virgin package like if you're
going cuz that's fastly I never thought
about that that you know there's some
young guys out there and they can get
that you know that bust out or they
can't get that you know the do you
notice that they do you feel like they
can't approach a woman do you feel like
it's that they the sex is the nervous
part for those guys it would it would
like I've been they've one in particular
told me that he you know had gone on
some dates and he told the girls like
hey I've never had sex before and it
kind of like scared the girls away
they're like oh I don't want to take
that on like I don't want to UM I don't
want to take your virginity that's like
too much pressure for a girl and like
and then it starts getting then they
don't want to you know turn into like
them being so much older and they
haven't had sex oh I think that's why
they're just like let me just contact
you know a high-end escort and do it
that way and get it over with and get
you know and you got that Pandora's box
really how many virginity's you feel
like you have inside of your vagina well
I took a couple before I became an
escort but I uh I don't know maybe ten
I'd not like a whole lot but and I'm
I've kind of already you're like the Tom
Brady of like taking virginity I feel
like that's a lot for my own sanity I've
decided to not see um clients that are
younger than me at this point like
anyone in their early twenties like I
just can't it's it's never like super
great for me I'm always like this is so
awkward they're always too awkward I'm
really good at making everybody feel
comfortable and like you know they enjoy
their experience it's all good like they
don't leave feeling like you know that
it was not it was less than stellar
because it I always take like really
great pride and what I do so for me
though it's just a lot to take on and I
just have decided not to do that anymore
and how long have you worked as a as a
sex worker um I've actually worked as a
sex worker for a really long time before
I started professional companionship but
I did everything from like videos and
photos online and webcaming I mean it
started with videos and photos and then
I started live webcaming and then I kind
of graduated too and the live webcam was
fun but it was just like everybody knew
my business like it was all over oh
really it was all over the Internet like
I had I you know oh yeah because guys
would go on there and you can peruse
through different ones and they might
find ya and it was just a live free
stream so like you know really I would
have like dudes that I knew they would
be like oh I'm watching you right now
I'm like can you please not do that
that's really awkward or someone would
record it without my knowing and it
would be on like pornhub or whatever and
then I'd get a friend that would send me
the link and be like oh I just found
this of you and then I'd have to have
pornhub take it off and now do you get a
little bit of excitement from that like
is there like kind of an
like is there something that's enticing
about seeing yourself on like a pornhub
or something like that
um well the pornhub part not so much but
because I have never actually done porn
but I feel like I've always been very
open to being an exhibitionist and like
being out of the box as far as like what
I do with my sexuality and what I do
with my body and who I earn okay so
you've been out of the box sorry I don't
mean to refuse okay
you've been out of the box by will you
say it one more time for me by being an
exhibitionist and you are very open yeah
very open
I'm always been super comfortable with
it and I've always been drawn to it I've
always been drawn to it I've always been
like I don't know I just knew from a
very young age I was gonna be completely
different than everybody else
have you ever was there somebody that
like was there did you ever have a pimp
or anything like that when you first got
into it no absolutely not um so when I I
had kind of like I guess a female
version of a pimp that kind of like got
me into webcaming and taught me how to
do it and she was like taking part of my
payment and I'm mad I'm a little bit
kind of gosh I can't I don't wanna go in
a house mom no like look how like an
online house mom I guess like she it was
everything was online like Ask Jeeves
but for [ __ ] kind of yeah kind of um
and then I kind of just got over that
because I wanted my privacy again but I
was still like into the idea of using my
sexuality to for my benefit and putting
about putting you know value on my
sexuality and putting value on my body
and using it to my advantage so I then
talked to a friend
this was like several years like I don't
know a couple years ago talk to a friend
and she was like you should get a sugar
daddy and I was like oh my god cuz you
know a lot of my like webcam clients
wanted to meet me and I was so freaked
out by that idea I was like there's no
way I could like ever break down this
fourth wall yeah or like there's no way
I could ever have sex with like one of
these dudes that are like giving me
money for like you know enjoying lurking
yeah yeah so I was like there's no way
and Nick does it a lot it seems like
somebody that does been sorry okay cool
if you do it anyway I mean like
sometimes I even to this day like to go
on and like look at the girls and all
like load some money and like give them
tips and stuff because I think it's
super fun
yeah um and so so then there was that
moment where you talked to another girl
she had a sugar daddy and she said
you've got it yeah maybe tried this and
I was like okay but she was like don't
do what I did she's like I did really
dangerous things I would just like you
know get on a plane and fly she said
actually like flew to Jamaica once and
like like without really knowing that
like the guy was gonna be super safe or
whatever there was really no like
screening practices like what I do now
but so I did that and when I figured out
was sugar daddies are extremely cheap
and manipulative and like it's just I
don't know if you're you're listening
and you have a sugar daddy they're
probably a blacklisted Escort client
because they're just though they'll be
really flashy with their money and like
I have all of this stuff but they will
be super cheap about like giving you you
know more than its it was just I wasn't
getting what I do mean Jewish or what
are you talking about just I was I had
one for like my very first one I had for
like seven months and he was just like
you don't want to be a you know I don't
I don't really want to say you know the
age oh okay are word because I hate that
word but he's like you don't want to do
that the hooker yeah he's like you you
don't want to do that that's dirty
that's disgusting he was like but then
he was still paying you to do it he was
paying me I got away with like I mean he
was not an attractive human whatsoever
and he just had a shitty personality and
I got away with like out of seven months
I think I only slept with him like five
times so I was able to like get you know
but he wouldn't get me enough to for me
to like save and like save and you know
I still had like a vanilla like regular
drop at the same time too and do you
feel then so these so the sugar daddy
thing I have a friend that
I am that goes on a lot of those sites
in as dates with those with the girls
from sinking arrangements
yes all the time right yeah all the time
I mean literally four nights a week and
he it's kind of you know I love the guy
it's a little gross sometimes the way he
yeah it's almost like shopping or
something for him in a way you know
which is which isn't bad I mean I think
he did he kind of just wants company you
know right right but it seems like for
some people that can get yeah it doesn't
seem like there's any benefit for the
women sometimes there's what it doesn't
seem there's very blurred boundaries and
you had like there there's so many girls
on there that are in the end the guys
are like oh well I I can get this much
for 200 right you know girls are doing
things for way less money than I would
do right at this point okay did you ever
get approached by one of those like sex
carnivals or anything like that did you
ever do like a traveling no sex thing
never because I'll tell you what
happened one time so I went to Europe
with a girlfriend and we were you know
we were having some intimacy
difficulties because that's really one
of my strong suits yeah you know
intimacy difficulties is one of my
strong suits and so and she's a
beautiful girl and so but we went to
they had one of these you know kind of
Croatian kind of [ __ ] circuses or
whatever we you could go you pay money
mm-hmm and you stand in like a a cage
and they put people out there on the
spinning wheel and they're [ __ ] you
know we're having sex right and then at
one point the wheel gets fat they add
more people in the wheel gets faster and
it's like it becomes a thing where you
can even bet on them and the last person
to be on the wheel you know wins or
whatever and they get the money you know
it's kind of like you got to take you
bet on a horse but the horse gets the
money right right but it was just fun
you know so if you want sheering you
know you see people and all these little
cages you're and you're in these little
we're in a box with a screen and so the
screen door would go up and you'd see
all the other creeps and the other
little things cheering on the you know
the people in the little you know Barnum
and you know but Funari or whoever they
were
you know I like Europe is way more open
right sexual like yes we got we
literally walked walked into there we're
in there for half hour walked out and it
didn't feel as crazy yeah as if they had
that here like they would have a bunch
of you know lonely like sad people
outside protesting it right I mean it's
um we've got this like really strange
like Puritan puritanical moral weirdness
in this country and I really don't
understand how or why yeah um I wish
that we were you know more open like
European countries are like it would be
better for everybody
um do you know um you know a lot of you
know to kind of get talked a little bit
about the law thing that happened like a
lot of a lot of the laws that were that
ever changes you can't is and and I'm
just gonna try to try to streamline in
here that you can't you can't advertise
on websites I'm like Backpage Craigslist
and stuff like that basically what it's
done is it's it the law itself has put
the websites hell they're now held
responsible for what third party users
post oh well so if it could be if it
could be you know described as
trafficking then the website is then
held accountable for now they have to
shut it down because yeah a lot of
websites have like shut down back page
that wasn't completely like that all
happened kind of like it was weird that
it was around the same time as testa
fossa but it was a different thing
um but yeah so things have shut down and
as well position 60 or something like
that yeah and a lot of celebrities came
out and pushed this and championed it
right as if to stop sex trafficking
right right um and you know to me it's
always seem like the sex trafficking
numbers in America have seen seemed way
overblown they're in play um yeah it's
like you hear like you know 200,000
women in a
our being sex trafficking stuff and I'm
like where are their trains running
through town like where are these people
you know because even you know when I
would you know have experiences with you
know hiring escort or something like
that or engaging with them at all you
know I never felt like oh this woman is
being sex trafficked no I don't know
anybody that's being you know coerced or
I have you met a lot of women like that
because there must be something that
that where that belief comes from um I
mean it's it is there it's out there but
the ironic thing about this bill is that
because they are now you know being
removed from online it's pushed it into
a dark dangerous place because now it's
moving to the streets and you know women
that did depend on that you know less
expensive advertising like Backpage and
you know just websites that were less
expensive to advertise on um they are
now being approached by pimps they're
now having to go work on the streets
it's become so much more dangerous and I
don't even know like how you know the
Department of Justice opposed this bill
they felt like it was going to squander
tax dollars because they're I mean
there's no it makes it more difficult
for them to find sex track traffic
victims because they're not being posted
online anymore right there's no track
and now there's no way to really track
them yeah now it's like we could end up
in more times where you have like a
Green River Killer or somebody like that
who's going it is picking these women up
it sounds like if there's going to be
more women out there I mean it's it's
basically made it it's made people that
are poor trans people women of color
people of color trans people of color
it's it's affected them the most out of
anybody why is that because I mean
they're they depended the most on those
Rebecca
yeah they mostly those advertising
platforms I agree when I would see when
I would be on those sites you know
because my thing is dude I would get you
know
when I was doing drugs out there I would
be doing drugs and I'd start you know
what do you say that this is you
mentioned the celebrities that were
against the trap with sex trafficking
okay I hate them all Ashton Kutcher is
your mortal enemy yeah I know it was
like Amy Schumer asked and Kutcher are
these people a Ricky Martin who else
Ashton Kutcher Demi Moore Carrie
Underwood Kristen Bell it's just um it's
a misguided like I understand like it's
hard especially for anyone you know who
feels missing lawmakers that are having
to vote for this it feels weird there's
only two that didn't vote for it and
they and you know um it it it's hard to
be like oh no I am against you know the
stop sex trafficking act like the way
that it was worded is so sneaky and I
really feel like what it actually did
was remove a lot of our freedoms as far
as using the internet goes agree so it's
it's actually a really dangerous bill
there was a lot yeah like the freedom
network which is the largest
organization of anti-sex trafficking or
it's the largest network of anti-sex
trafficking organizations they
completely opposed this well yes yeah
yeah we'll just took in okay this is
what we think about it so this is what
it should be
let's name it the stop sex trafficking
of course everyone wants to stop sex
trafficking right but this wasn't the
way to do it and we also don't want we
don't want consent consensual sex
workers to be lumped in with sex traffic
victims because people like myself are
completely like I'm doing it on my own
volition I enjoy my job I love my job
everybody that I know that you know my
colleagues that I you know I network
with which I network a lot with a lot of
other women we all really enjoy our job
and a lot of us really truly believe
that like we're helping people and the
reason why I'm I feel activated to talk
about cesta FASTA and the people that
are disenfranchised by it is because I'm
in a position that I'm I'm okay right I
I've really not been affair
did too much by this I mean it was it
was scary when it happened in April like
it was very like we didn't know it was
really uncertain like you know we use
online black lists that are you know our
secret black lists that that girls can
log into and and find if a client had
hurt somebody or raped somebody or
assaulted or you know dangerous people
right we use those to keep ourselves
safe we use each other to keep ourselves
safe like we you know can reach out to
other it must makes it harder to do that
this makes it yeah the the black lists
that I use removed as soon as assess -
Fausta came or it happened they removed
a lot of their postings so for girl said
you know John Smith dress up like Paul
Bunyan and chase me with an axe you know
yeah painting me blue and chase me with
an ass like had an actual net on there
anymore had an actual description of
what happened linked to this person's
name and phone number and email the
phone number and email and the name
still come up and it's still flagged as
a black list but that whole description
is completely gone right and I think
even in some cases they changed from
dangerous to just time-waster right
which a time-waster sucks there's so
many of them I feel like that's all of
the people that are on seeking
arrangement but we need to know the
difference between a time-waster and
someone that's [ __ ] dangerous like
it's just so I've depended heavily upon
like references from other girls like I
will not see my screening actually has
gotten even tighter and it's completely
opposite for a lot of people that don't
have that art in my position they're
screening they have basically not been
able to screen right they just they need
to make ends meet like I think there was
a and a lot of the women on the sites I
do say you know just just to get back to
that was yeah it seemed like a lot of
impoverished women yes you know that's
exactly you definitely saw it was a lot
of black women it was a lot of you know
or not but here's what I would say it
was a lot of black women but it was also
a lot of poor looking women yes and I
say that because I grew up around a lot
of poor looking women and I know what
they look like and
these were some of them that's what I'm
saying
there was a right around that time this
sex work obviously advocacy group took a
survey of about 300 sex workers asking
like what happened you know what their
life situation is like you know post
fascist esta and I think it's like oh
yeah 77 percent are the sole providers
of their family and 89 percent have 1 to
6 dependents yeah on them so it's you
know when you can't I feel like a lot of
ignorance is like oh well they can just
go get another job but right absolutely
not the case
right and why did celebra I wonder so
sex trafficking became like this you
know every couple of months there's a
new thing it's like the buzzy thing that
celebrities get on board with because it
keeps their name in the limelight I
think a lot of times but they see it as
like oh I'm bringing attention to this
issue right and it makes sense if
somebody's like oh would you stop sex
trafficking sure yeah a hundred percent
how would you say then that you try and
stop sex trafficking but not inhibit the
women that you're talking about and that
you and I are talking about like other
women like is there a way to do it you
have a like you have another idea do you
think and I'm just thinking out loud
here I'm not like putting it you know I
mean harm reduction decriminalization I
mean I think those are like our two main
things that we need to focus on like
we've like this laws the opposite of
harm reduction right it has caused a lot
of harm like I I've seen countless posts
on Twitter about like hey my friend had
to go hit the streets last night she's
missing or my friend committed suicide
or my friend is in ICU she got beat up
by about client like it's it's gotten
like out of control so I don't and I
don't know like where are the victims
that were helped by this like please
show me yeah it's another thing like and
I remember I would go to like cuz I've
been I said before like different sex
trafficking events over the years and
stuff and a lot of the times the videos
and stuff the things that I would see it
some of these places I'm just like where
is this going
like they'd show all the videos of women
from a lot of other countries and I
think I
definitely think it's happening more in
other countries right for sure but it's
like I've never been around an
environment I've never you know even in
you know having experiences with escorts
that I've never been like oh these are
these women's seams sex traffic but now
what about a woman that has a pimp like
that seems like an uncomfortable
situation sometimes pimps take advantage
of vulnerable women right um and if we
had a way if it was decriminalized if we
had a way to protect ourselves if we did
have a badge on by going to the police
and not being punished for prostitution
right I feel like it would completely
cut out the middleman like a pimp would
not be necessary yeah if we were able to
feel safe at work hmm right I see what
you're saying I mean we I'm say we as my
community a lot of this stuff doesn't
necessarily apply to me because of the
position I'm in yeah but um you know
like I'm just talking about it because
it needs to be talked about talked about
and put out there because it's super
important and not a lot of people know
about it to be honest
we're really pushed into the dark with
this yeah well it felt to me like
whenever this thing came out I was like
this doesn't seem this seems like a lot
of people who don't know
yeah it just seemed like well how are
these women who are using this as a
regular tool to live and to subsidize
their families and provide what are
these women supposed to do because I
don't see train fulls of you know
impoverished Sri Lankan women being
bused across America you know what I'm
saying like I mean I can imagine that
there's definitely some you know some
shady brothels and stuff like that going
on but even the guys that I know to get
it they go to get involved in that they
go down to Mexico they go down to
Tijuana now I do know that like you know
off a Manchester and Inglewood and stuff
like that there's a lot of like trap
houses like I know a lot of NFL athletes
used to go they have like this famous
kind of trap house in Miami like robbing
tugs well it was more like a place where
they would keep like five or six hot
like Instagram models
got it and it would be sort of like a
sexual weekend or something you know and
these are you know some of this are
things that these aren't things that
I've been to but these are things that I
feel like I've heard enough about like
from different people where it's like
okay this is a thing that's kind of
going on even things that I've been
giving business cards to go to well
let's lighten it up a little bit so what
is um and look this is this is really
interesting right I did really like I
really wanted to talk about that because
it's so important it's very important
and that's one of the reasons why you
know we we've even been trying to find
you or someone like you to come in and
talk I mean we've been looking for
someone for almost six months ya know
even looking for someone census was a
really you know a hot issue right that
if women can't advertise on these places
then where does a woman who's you know
who doesn't cuz you're at cut you're
more you you're more like an elite
companionship fans days I am but you
recognize and you're not afraid to at
least you know acknowledge that not
everybody has that luxury yeah and I I
were all sex workers we're all like
incenting this like I am no better than
you know a woman that's sucking dick on
the street for $50 like I really don't
consider myself any better I want to
help that woman yeah I just attended
last week I went to the sex workers
outreach project committee meeting
because I do want to get more involved
with volunteering and helping and doing
my part and I think I do feel activated
to do that because of how much I love my
job and how much it's like sex work has
completely changed my life
and really yeah for the better
completely in okay and let's get back so
let's get back to that but I want to
keep it I want to keep this like you
know Nick will you write that down
please how sex work has changed for life
completely
let's tell me a story of like something
that's kind of a wild that that would be
interesting or just tell me a story I
have so many interesting stories do you
yeah I had to actually sit down last
night and discuss that's why I have this
little note card because I needed to
like jog my memory about some things but
okay cuz I've been doing this so my
Homer sory is April
sixteen okay started around April 2016 I
started seeing my first clients and you
got those through camming No
so there was this website that was
around pre cesta FAFSA and it's no
longer around it was like a review site
mhm
it was a way that guys would use it to
avoid being ripped off by like a
bait-and-switch like a girl
whose pictures they're seeing but then
they show up and that's not the girl oh
yeah so they were using it for that but
then it turned into this like you know
it would be this like the juicy details
and like I mean it was really
incriminating to be honest like there
was a lot of you know it was like a Yelp
page for sex workers right uh anywhere
from like massages to high-end
companionship or whatever so that was
there and they that community made like
a meet-and-greet back in like April 2016
and really I would be can greet between
the workers and the guys and the clients
and there was a there was a forum on
this website so a lot of guys were like
really active on this forum which is so
mind-blowing to me that like anyone
would spend their time being active on a
like escort review site like Jeanette L
was a real feisty and then some of them
we called him hobbyist some of them were
really just like you know and they would
they would call us hookers and they
would talk [ __ ] sorry I should not drink
Lacroix um they were like yeah they were
just kind of we call we like we call
them so obvious because okay it's called
a hobby and then they would be the
hobbyists and we're the providers and
then the ones that were just you know
really into the Hobby we would call them
lobbyists okay so there was this mean
greed and I was linked with a girl you
know completely like outside in like my
vanilla life like I I was given the
contact information of high-end escort
and her and I started talking and
actually I first got introduced because
she couldn't make it to something and
she asked if I wanted to go instead of
sub-sub so that you got a shot
this all comes full circle because
so I show up to this hotel and there's
five other girls I want to say okay and
it's this really tiny old little Asian
man and he loves having like five six
girls for one hour and he calls it a
party and he like brings roses and
chocolate-covered strawberries and this
whole thing it was what's he wearing
um slacks and a shirt
I just know Asia I was talking to these
other girls before this individual
arrived before this gentleman arrived
and they were like I was like yeah I do
sugar baby stuff and I don't know I'm
kind of a little afraid to like go full
into professional escorting they're like
oh my god it's so much better like it's
good to have the boundaries the time
limits everything and I'm like yeah it
does sound like it would be like better
for me mentally because this like these
issues that I was having with the sugar
daddies with like with the no boundaries
and the manipulation and like just it
was all bad it was really dark it was a
dark period in my life um so cuz the men
have all the power yes they do and I
mean I feel so badly for the girls that
/ I mean there's a ton of them I feel so
badly don't participate on that so many
and because I think this like sugar baby
lifestyle is like really like inflated
on social media yet I'm on this yeah you
never see any of the old dudes in the
background I see any you just never
realized what's really going on and yeah
that's impact but it's impact but there
must be something empowering about that
but you're saying it sounds like for you
it turned more like in a business um
well no the guys are just honestly those
guys are just [ __ ] shitty they're just
users they don't they yeah they want to
get as much as they can for as little as
possible buddy that does it honestly you
know that's exactly how he is yeah they
want that's why they're and I think
honestly a lot of them are blacklisted
clients because you know escorts stick
to their [ __ ] boundaries right we're
like no I will not see you for less than
my right sorry
move along yeah dude that's crazy cuz
when I with you whenever I already I
would like get it whenever I was doing
drugs I would get all high and lie
you know I'd still want to interact with
people but there's nobody interact with
you so skate you can't have people come
over to your house your buddies and just
hide in Burton you're not doing cocaine
you know just hide behind the plants in
your own house
so then I would start you know it's
engaging with escorts offer websites
text in them and just negotiate and
rates do but it wouldn't need but I
would always be too scared to have them
caught like how it was that was way too
much I got so much anxiety a lot of
people do like that's not time waster
you were time waster thank you so what
am i gold yes I was a time when you were
a time waster yeah I mean and you know I
find that I don't struggle with that you
know even engaging in you know looking
at those types of websites anymore and
it's okay so I've gotten sober ya know
I'm not saying it isn't but for me it
was more of a you know it was I don't
know it was I was just lonely I guess
I was lonely an apartment that any
Marilla I just wanted anybody to be
around just wanted to engage with anyone
and these some of the only people don't
engage with you if you're you know it
where it doesn't matter if you're high
or whatever you know no judgment
whatsoever I think that's what is so
great about what I do is I there's
there's a need and I provide service for
that need you know whether someone's
lonely or going through something I mean
you know I kind of completely
sidetracked off my story but I have
clients that were like I was going
through a really dark period of my life
and you really helped me
mmm I've been told that numerous times
and it makes me feel like so good that
I'm actually like they're like thank you
so much for the service that you do
because there are lonely people but then
at the same time I see people that are
like just super [ __ ] busy or that um
I guess tell me about the Asian for so
the Asian part you're they are these my
girls five girls talking to the girls
and then I just remember it was this you
know we're all just like acting bananas
I think I was drinking and they were all
drinking and is it a nice hotel room
yeah it was nice it was fine um did the
guy show up yeah he showed up it was an
hour it was super easy because there was
like so many girls so it was just like a
couple of us would like be in the corner
tending to like eat each other out but
we weren't really were just like making
the noises and giggling and then and I'm
sure he knows that if they break up that
party shrimp or what'd he do what's
fred-weiner bro oh yeah that jeopardy
nur I'm really am I where I'm actually
so impressed by this older gentleman
like that he can just like hit it way
really [ __ ] five chicks yeah it was
pretty impressive now what do you mean
like it the you mean that in a stage
fright sense kind of you know like he
was just going for it and everyone is
not give up I mean obviously there was a
lot of hygienic things that were
happening in between each girl right but
I mean it was so then actually that then
just happened last week I I had some
girl that I've never met before reached
out to me via email and was like hey can
you come and see this I was like I know
the client that you're talking about
I've seen him before it was been a long
time so I ended up going and there was
only four of us this time for girls it's
like a welcome back kotter economist so
you know I've seen in he he either
pretends he doesn't know me or just does
not remember me at all so and the first
time I saw him I was like a completely
different name so this time I had a
different name and everything and he
like totally did not I didn't remember
me at all and I was like that's really
bizarre but whatever I guess that works
so I ended up seeing doing that again
just you know last week okay now this
one half years of not doing it did you
take more control this time in the
scenario because you've been in it
before how did it feel differently like
it's just comparing one we were all
working together to just like you know
move things along we were like you know
it was an afternoon we're like we have
to you know keep this under an hour
traffic yeah we have to you know okay
it's time to you know we were all just
like it was a very smooth teamwork we
were all like okay now let's you know
put your condom on okay now we're gonna
do this in this and okay now it's time
to like I don't know we really like it
was a snow spank and his people were
laughing we were licking each other's
tails we were like someone was keeping
him busy and then the other girls were
like and I kind of like lost my
composure a couple times I was like
laughing but it's all I mean it was kind
of fun because it was like an
opportunity to act like a complete you
know right
and where all that body activity does
anybody ever like fart or to turn it I
feel like that would happen I got a
friend that told me about it and you
can't lay it off right you don't yeah I
mean it's never happened to me but I had
a friend that told me that she would um
she a couple of times she's pass gas
she's like whatever it's just part of
the experience
oh wow she was very confident and I'm
very this job as made me so much more
confident with myself like you know if
it did happen I would just be like well
whatever that's a body yeah yeah um as
part of the experience brother yeah an
extra 40 bucks yeah
charge on that tune-up like like where
they like a my form of companionship is
called the girlfriend experience so I
guess we can just chalk it up as part of
the girlfriend experience okay and what
are you charge what are the what is a
what is that like oh you want me to
discuss my reads I mean is that okay to
talk about her you don't feel like
talking it's up to you um I don't know
should specifically state what my rates
are but okay can I you know is it
so for mm you know is it like above $500
an hour okay yes okay yeah and if there
are are their experiences everywhere you
go you stay overnight you say okay I've
um flown places I've been flown places I
only work in LA and then I do work in
New York a couple times a year so I do
have clients the thing also about my
type of companionship is I have the same
people that I see I should have like a
regular clientele oh okay I see and is
it hard to establish that it takes time
it takes time it takes time for sure I
feel like if I would have theirs I've
seen a couple girls pop up that are new
since cesta Faust and I'm like wow what
a nightmare
like that cannot be easy to completely
start fresh in like the post you know
with Oliver like a lot of our resources
are gone and like I don't know lucky
luckily for me when I started I did have
a little bit saved up from my sugaring
stuff so I was able to you know hire
someone to do good photos and hires you
like it all costs a lot of money to keep
the
appearances of you know high-end and
experience okay so you have a website
you have all that sort of yes okay Wow
so it's it's like a business it's a
commits totally a business I in fact I
have an LLC I pay taxes I'm an
accountant I you know I run I run my
business completely on my own I've
considered getting a an assistant but I
just into type a like I would need
everything in my own control yeah the
whole time even though it's so much
extra work but I feel you and especially
like you know a lot of a lot 90% of my
my job is weeding through emails and
really like this is like Nick yeah
just total [ __ ] what are so like one
of the wildest things that somebody's
you know as a John or somebody has hired
you to get involved in because I picture
like doing jousting you ever get out
there and I gotta animals in there you
know I'm saying they got raccoons out
there something like that I feel like I
got an email just the other day of I got
a snake in your something you know dude
a reptile magic or something I don't
think any I couldn't I don't I've had
you know I had someone had mentioned
animals and that just completely
disturbed me so I [ __ ] that um I had
someone email me and I'm not gonna
return this email but they stated my
weight in my height and then a
girlfriend a colleague that I work with
because I have a couple girls that I do
doubles with so and they are listed on
my website and I'm listed on their
website and it's you know well-known
that we work together but he was like
you know I know that you're this height
in this way and your friend is this
height in this way would you be able to
hold her for long periods of time and
throw her around and like I was like
well I was it was funny because I'm like
I'm not like a power lifters well that I
was just imagining me like struggling
naked trying to throw my girlfriend on
to around a hotel and it just seemed
like the weirdest um yeah I don't know
so most honestly most of my work is
completely just normal and vanilla like
I don't really I've had a couple
experiences that work him like
really just out of out of the norm
I can like yeah what's up yeah like
about a year and a half ago I had a
there was a double with a girlfriend of
mine and it was a guy that I don't think
I'd seen before and he comes in and
they're all body polish or something
like that when you go over there for
this stuff do you put on moisturizer and
all that I take very good care of my
body yeah
your skin looks nice thank you I am in
tip-top shape all the time I don't you
know but my body is my work so I keep it
as yeah everything is completely clean I
get tested constantly I've never had an
STD that's actually we have a lower STD
rate in the escort community than in
real life because we are so adamant
about protection and definitely then at
Virginia Tech University of drove
through there wanting we could
definitely you could smell it in the air
or something going on over there yeah in
Blacksburg
so yeah I'm all I'm all like freshened
up I look good
okay so whether the experience you were
gonna tell me about yes so it's my
girlfriend and my and myself and it said
our in call and this guy comes over and
he like he looks cute surprisingly a lot
of my clients are like really attractive
I have a lot of attractive clients and
it's like I'm always like thank you but
he comes over and he's like somewhat
attractive from the start like from the
first impressions and I think it was
opposed to be like 90 minutes or at two
hours or something like that and um he
wanted like you know he wanted I think
he either wanted double penetration for
my friend cuz I don't do but stuff but
my friend does but stuff and we have a
strap on her and I went and bought a
strap-on together okay and it turned out
that he wanted to be pegged while he was
[ __ ] her and I was like okay I'll do
the pegging and we owe them poked a
motive they call that boy know what I'm
saying we use this like dance it's like
you had a shelf Grampy pillow things
like - so she was laying on her back and
then he was on her and then I think so
he was doing kind of a missionary style
but buttocks work yeah and I was
complete
we in the behind him in the back yeah
sheared you in the back man you that for
us grant you remember this had been I
mean there was like all kinds of fooling
around and stuff before this before this
happened and I remember like the time
was starting to run up and this guy was
not coming and I was like okay we need a
leg wrap this up um and oh yeah and
another thing the guy took his shirt off
and he had a belly button ring and I was
like um it was Joe exotica or not he's a
famous cat tamer slash murderer
bellybutton ring really through really I
was like you were cute until I saw the
bellybutton ring and I was like oh God
and then I just guy in our town used to
keep a spare house key on it all the
time because he always would lose his
keys how exotic
got it oh so so this guy wasn't comin he
was no he wasn't coming and I was
looking at the clock and I felt like I
mean my hips my hips were getting sore
cuz I was like doing all your backyard
doing that with my strap-on Wow and then
is that exciting is that an exciting
experience I was just like wow this is
so I mean it was just in the middle of
the day it was just like a weekday in
the middle and I'm like I can't believe
like this sometimes very surreal like
two o'clock in the afternoon
oh that's was there Friday or something
like it was just I was like sometimes I
just have these surreal moments where
I'm like wow this is what I'm doing like
when other people are just completely
normal and I'm like completely normal
like all aboard like are you like cold
yeah and pretty much and any of this so
the man's not ejaculating at the time
was timer spiking and I remember my hips
were starting to hurt and then this like
kind of weird smell was happening and I
was like that's getting to be really
unpleasant and then I was hitting my
threshold which I don't hit my threshold
too often but I was like my threshold
was and I was like we got a I started so
I was like we got it I'm sorry dude we
gotta wrap this up and he's like oh well
I think he said something about the time
you know he's like well you guys you
guys should have told me that that you
had to end this I think was like 3:30
and you know that's how that's the
amount of time that he paid for so my
friend who has no filter she's like well
in hooker time
you know 90 minutes is 90 minutes we
don't have to tell you at the beginning
of the appointment that it will be over
90 minutes you should just be done in 90
minutes yeah so like it ended up like it
was just the whole I don't know I think
we we ended up like patching it up right
at the end and I think he ended up
coming and stuff but it was just like oh
my god it was so much work and it was
like yeah it was one of my least
favorite experiences I have to say so
one thing I've been thinking about
recently is my body and a different
types of thing that's on my body and
stuff like that and different types of
sometime you have different fabrics
touching against your skin maybe you
know leather or cotton or you know
burlap or mogadishu but now everything
has changed and that's why me undies has
that most beautiful mode al and it's
three times as soft as cotton Veera felt
cotton and if you never felt cotton
cotton is that stuff that's in the top
of vitamins if you get vitamins and you
open it up you get a free chunk of
cotton but now that stuff is soft
something you'll take that vitamin
cotton and hide it under your nuts or
whatever but now that's all changed
because me undies has these beautiful
three times as soft as cotton Modell
undies and they have that sharks on them
they have all different types of things
so if you want to take a bite out of
somebody else's crotch you can get that
hitter pair right there you go to meet
undies dot-com / weekend to get 15% off
your first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed
they have multiple fun prints each month
100% satisfaction guaranteed if you
don't like them you can mail them back
so go to meet undies comm slash weekend
for 15% off your first pair of free
shipping meet undies so did did timing
does the time if a guy ejaculates is
that when the time is up no because my
time you're paying for my companionship
of my time and whatever happens in that
time is is so the Queen to content
consensual adults okay and if the guy
busts out or whatever and you could you
got 30 minutes life you guys can sit
down and watch ever
buddy loves Raymond or you some pretty
much I mean I have a I have a couple of
regular clients that I like I'll just
you know a lot of my regulars booked me
for like three four hours so it's like a
really relaxed I'll go to dinner I even
have a couple clients that just take me
to dinner like I don't have sex with
them like they just booked me for hours
to hang out and spend time and they
really like enjoy me and they enjoy
talking to me and yeah we had to do
growing up I remember this guy I mean
this is I don't know it's maybe think
this way this dude named Carl in our
neighborhood and he would give you like
thirty bucks and he'd walk like 15 20
feet away from you and hold his butt
open for you to look at his butthole and
as long as you sat there and looked at
it he was you know he was fine with you
keeping the money I had just looking at
scary about home before him really yeah
and I will you say scary what does that
mean so someone I just saw once and he
ended up actually contacting me a year
later and then he ended up being like a
real time waster in the wing I just was
like [ __ ] this very little patience for
that stuff now but so I ended up meeting
him at a hotel and he was in really good
shape he told me he did CrossFit and you
know he's a younger guy owned his own
business which is a lot like honestly a
lot of my clients but um he the way he
wanted me to suck his dick I was like
laying on the bed with my head kind of
hanging off hmm
and then he was standing over me so the
daughter they call that that baby otter
dude if you doing that hanging your head
off the back of the baby yeah so his
dick was going down my throat like
upside down occasionally and so I had a
like perfect my eyes were in direct
sight line to his butthole and he I
think he was trying like and I noticed
his butthole like looked like an outie
belly button kind of like a whoa pretty
like I prolapsed maybe I don't know you
butthole
I don't know if it's like maybe
hemorrhoids or I don't know but it was
really freaky it was just it was
freaking me out and I was like oh my god
I cannot believe my eyes are like four
inches wet again I just eat nationally
you know maybe had a tart lime or so I
don't know what happened to that
butthole but then he pulled his dick out
of my mouth and was like trying to get
me too rim him and I was like no really
no really
Wow then and pretty much like and I
think it he was like oh okay okay I'm
like thanks get that bottle the [ __ ]
away from me right
wow yeah so people showing up with wild
body parts of missing like some very
small wieners and stuff like that as
well yeah I mean I have to note here
that I don't have any judgements on any
Blake I really don't we're just telling
the story
yeah for sure I I don't care how old you
are what your body looks like if you
have weird body hair if like I just care
that you are clean and you smell nice if
you have a hygiene problem I have a
[ __ ] issue yeah I have a really
sensitive nose and just I I I take
really good care of my hygiene and I
feel like if you don't like I've had
I've had like a couple really like this
is not and is there any specific type of
man that has that that often doesn't
come through with that soapy you know
definitely a lot of escorts tweet about
this on Twitter like please double wash
your testicles and your bowl your dick
like please soap it twice and a lot of
men only wash their crotch around
Christmastime at the holidays yeah
that's true because that more time in
the shower around and they're visiting
family yeah dudes just don't I don't
know like it's not a thing we need it we
need it we need to like that's a psia
like please please wash your balls like
sweaty ball smell is just the worst it
just sticks it it really sticks with you
yeah yeah it's like having a little baby
you know it's like just having like a
little baby India yeah luckily I'm a
baby India yeah I look luckily that
doesn't happen too often like I you know
I keep really strong smelling soap
available in my incall so please use
like the really like make it smell nice
okay let's get to a couple questions we
had some questions that came in from
listeners not specifically for you
obviously but just you know we let them
know that we're having a sex worker on
today we had some questions that came in
you weren't one of those yeah actually
had one too uh you have a question yeah
are you ever like do you have an exit
strategy at all
like are you do you ever want to be
monogamous like it because you can't up
I guess you could do it forever but
that's an excellent question um I do I'm
in school full-time and I do plan on I
mean obviously I'm anonymous and I don't
show my face on my advertisements or my
website or anything so I do plan on
stopping when some time after graduation
but like I don't know I feel like I
enjoy it so much like I don't know I I
do you know I have like I have mixed
ideas about monogamy to be honest but I
do like want to eventually you know I
have been in relationships while I've
been doing this and it's not the easiest
thing ever I prefer to be single while I
do this it just makes it harder for me
and harder for you know the person I'm
in a relationship with because a lot of
people don't understand that it's just
work like I have a completely separate
like I compartmentalize my work and it's
just completely different for me so I
did something like HAP like was there
you feel like there was a thing in your
life that happened that made it that way
for you with sex because you know people
always feel like you know if someone's a
sex worker that they you know they were
molested or they were in danger that
they had a bad sexual experience I've
never been molested I've never been had
a bad sexual experience I don't know I
just really enjoy sex and I've decided
to put you know put value to it and and
it's I feel like my self-worth and my
self-respect has only increased since I
started like I just I value my own time
a lot more - yeah yeah and it's like if
that's your trade it's like if somebody
could do origami mm-hm and they in
they're good at it you know then I'll be
damned if they shouldn't be out there
making Swans you know if they can or
making you know whatever those birds are
they say they're swans but they don't
even look like swans I just I just like
to [ __ ] I like I am I've always been
funny I just decided to be a
professional [ __ ] yeah and it's
organizing and control it exactly right
exactly
a lot of people have a lot of issues
with the fact that women can monetize
that it's and but a lot of women seem to
have a lot of issues with it though
I respect pot like I don't have any you
know I mean I have issues with my own
you know desires to act out in ways of
watching pornography and ways of
reaching out to you know are considering
sex work as opposed to considering
reaching out to sex workers as opposed
to as ways to steer away from trying to
be in brave enough to abstain a
committed relationship and that sort of
thing like the temptations of those and
like you know but I don't disrespect it
at all as I think it's a really healthy
way to UM a healthy way to take care of
those things your being responsible both
parties understand the agreement
yeah there's no it's not an affair you
know it's I'm getting what I need by you
know my getting my money and you're
getting what you need like it's a
complete transactional healthy you know
a healthy way it's non messy like yeah
there's no strings attached whatsoever
once you leave once you part ways even
if I have to speak again I like that you
got that virginity inbox going on I
can't believe you have ten virginity's
inside me yeah but a rough estimate I
don't know but that do for a lot of guys
it's like there's such a stigma around
that and you can't hide being a virgin
dude there's no way to hide it it's like
your shirt fits differently when you're
a virgin like it's tighter right you
know it's tight around the neck
everything is you know you can't like
you can't you can like see really far
but you can't [ __ ] hear that go when
you're a virgin like just everything is
so built up inside of you you know
you're just looking for sex you know I
remember just they have one kid in our
class and you just kept being a virgin
and kept being a virgin in a college
dude and then he just it looked like he
was like nine years old and everybody
else was like thirty you know yeah and
then fine yeah finally he got some sex
and it just check everything about him
changed dude he [ __ ] you know he I
remember he took the tires off of his
car the name man and just [ __ ] just
yeah just did a bunch of just [ __ ]
you know dirty just me just making metal
tracks in his yard yeah it's an idiot
it's important yeah I think this is a
like what everyone needs to
understand this is a completely healthy
and normal part of life and if you know
you pay people to do everything you pay
people to be your therapist you pay
people to trim your lawn you pay people
to clean your teeth like why not pay you
pay people to do your hair like why not
pay someone to provide this service for
you it's a need that nut catcher what do
we have Nick we got some great calls and
questions that came in from our
listeners I want to thank our listeners
you know as always you can submit
questions video questions even now Theo
von comm slash podcast slash podcasts
and you drop accent link and you can
record yourself and upload it and it's
really easy and this Dropbox link and
you can record yourself there and upload
a video all right then let's get to a
couple of questions that came in and and
and also you can leave audio questions
in nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three kpo
this is Kayla calling from Sacramento
I'm kind of common to asked her kind of
what her take is on with her job as far
as like empowerment and how like it I
despise her I've recently kind of
started contemplating the ideas of
sugaring and just in that I've gotten so
much backlash and a lot of hate from
close friends surprisingly even despite
the political climate were in anyway um
more power to her [ __ ] yeah I like that
question um like I kind of mentioned
before um I feel like sex work I saw
this tweet a while ago it said a life
hack sex work and I feel like it has
been a life hack I was able to
completely fix my [ __ ] up credit I was
able to get out of debt I've been able
to like completely support my best
friend through her school I've supported
myself through school I've been
completely on my own like I at one point
in my life I've been on food stamps and
didn't have a vehicle and rode a bike
for a few years and it's been nothing
but empowering and such a positive
experience I've I was if I thought it
was gonna be like this dark kind of
seedy thing and it's been completely
opposite of that it's been nothing but
positive
like I but then I do a lot of things to
take care of myself my emotional health
I have a special therapist that sees sex
workers I have you know a very close
safety net of friends that really
support and love me I guess like my only
words for her is that sugaring you know
my opinion on triggering is not a it's I
feel like they're they just want to get
the most for the least amount of right
most people are snakes they're really
yes and also as far as like your friends
go I feel like if anyone judges you for
something that you want to do with your
own body like maybe they're not like the
best friend like I feel like everyone
should have their own but see if I can
do what I feel like we should be able to
do what we want with our bodies 100% but
it's the fun the interesting is like I
wouldn't want my sister's doing it you
know why because I guess I would be
scared for them you know I would be
nervous I know how men can be and you
know in that at certain points when
you're dealing with sex it's a lot of
like instinctual type of stuff it's like
you know things that can override a
man's thoughts and stuff like that and
so I think for me it would just be fear
you know now if one of them did of
course I would speak how I felt about it
with them you know Brandon's ex chair
those things but I would still you know
I wouldn't not loved him or you know try
and be as I guess supportive as I could
even though it would probably hard for
me to sometimes you know yeah I mean
what the whole purpose of this is I want
this to become a safer environment for
everyone to be able to do what they want
to do with their bodies and make their
own choices even as far as clients go
like a client should be able to choose
whether or not he sees a sex worker and
not have to face the stigma of Society
over it like it's yeah like I cited in
European countries it's a completely
different it's way more open can you
still have love though and have sex work
you know that's something that makes me
think like man will eventually
everybody's just gonna be sex workers
and everything's just going to be
and then nobody's gonna be in love
anymore absolutely I've I've been in
love while doing this and it was just
the wrong place wrong time
but I I felt like my love was completely
unaffected by my work like I was just
able to you know I'm able I'm I I do my
best friend tells me I'm a special human
all the time because I am able to
separate emotions from sex but but a lot
of women probably can a lot of women can
tonight
sex work isn't for everybody I can't I I
also need to stress that it's not for
everybody
right I know it was the right choice for
me and I know a lot of my friends that
do it it's the right choice for them and
you enjoy you know it's not for
everybody
yeah we're not saying if your car's
broken go [ __ ] make a website yeah
don't go sugaring just because you are
you know seeing the fantasy of it on
Instagram like yeah you have no I mean I
especially nothing was more shady than
when I was sugaring I can that [ __ ] was
shady as [ __ ] there was some there was
not good things happening that has not
happened while I've been in escort so do
you feel like Ivy ously with sugaring
it's a lot of guys they get on these
sites there's no exact terms a lot of
times I've never been involved in this
but I hear I hear about it firsthand one
of it all the time from a friend of mine
right and a friend who I would never let
date a sister of mine or even let her be
around him probably for the weekend but
also who I is still a buddy and and I
love him you know I'm a funny guy like
you know I can separate that for me as
his friend but but yeah he gets on these
things he you know he tells it he'll
take him out to somewhere nice they go
to somewhere nice and then there's never
any like payment or compensation a lot
of them it seems like feel like they
need to have sex in order to keep the
guy around and then the guy never calls
them again yep look that's my experience
with sugaring I went to nice dinners and
stuff and then it was like this like
taboo to even talk about like oh how
much money am I gonna get and like they
would almost make you feel bad for even
at like it was so there was just no
clear boundaries there was no right and
that gives you nothing as the it was
just such an I mean son I did get money
I was
able to like you know have somewhat of a
little savings built up from that but it
was so it was very laborious it was I
mean it was a lot of work it was a lot
of work yeah and what type of girls get
like where is there a moment for girls
where they think about getting a
sugaring where they can they can what
could they do at a certain moment to do
something else and not get into any of
it um not a not not getting involved
with any sex work yeah nothing online
nothing I mean I don't know I guess sex
work is the same as any work like I mean
minimum wage retail I guess like I think
that's like I worked retail to like I
think that's like that's the the kind of
pit you fall into either retail or even
like serving at a restaurant or whatever
or I mean go to school I don't know like
yeah I guess [ __ ] worked at a um hot
topic for a while dude actually had
electrocuted once at a hot topic I fell
into a box and [ __ ] beavis and
butt-head lamps and we got electrocuted
I feel like I was I was um I was a
coerced enforced and and living my worst
life when I worked retail more way more
then oh I'd rather blow a dude fold one
more shirt at every damn shirt hey I
worked at Sports Authority and I was the
best damn shoe insole salesman Eden
Prairie Minnesota ever had yeah well we
got I could see that okay we got a video
question here that came in from our
video fan line here we go
ello Theodore I got a question for your
charlatan friend I'm not Walker I was
just seeing if she ever fell in love
well tootin doing her job thank you
again this is Joe from Rockville
Maryland
whoo-hoo rah he was gonna say at the end
thank you Joe for uh and toot and some
people say bah you know I have a toot
and they say prostitute you know tootin
yeah - there was I saw like a little
train with Thomas the Train engine and
it was like if she doing it from the
loot she got prostitutes out there man -
um I don't know if you meant like with a
client or I've had a
like I said I I was in love with someone
completely outside of my job that I knew
them and as far as clients go I have
never been in love with a client I've
had a couple clients fall in love with
me I have had good like physical
chemistry with a couple clients where
I'm just like whoa where the my
pheromones like their pheromones and
yeah and it was with people obviously
that I would never encounter it's lazy
yeah I would never encounter in my real
life so um but no I've never fallen in
love with a client have you ever seen
somebody have like the nicest pair of
nuts you've ever seen or anything like
that nice pair of nuts I don't I mean I
think sometimes I don't think about
other dudes nuts but sometimes I wonder
if everybody has like the same nuts if
everybody has like different nuts
I've seen some really pretty dicks
really yeah I've seen some pretty ones
like and what do you mean kind of just
nice shape like perfect size you know
well groomed it looks good it smells
nice do they hang straight down or so
you they have to hang one way or the
other what is it I've seen a couple I
mean I've seen him hang all which weighs
like wow curved up curved down Kurt the
psyche or the other side oh yeah every I
mean that's a thing like it's trying to
peek around a cantaloupe my buddy had
that Dick's are all different and I
think everyone expects vaginas to all be
the same or that vaginas get stretched
out like can you imagine if a dick got
smaller every time you've had sex like
oh this vagina maid Shrunk my deck
that's pretty much the same as saying oh
I've used that excuse before so yes I
can't imagine that dick has stretched
out of Aegina um let's take another
question here did you answer that one
did we answer that one we did and a lot
of the questions left we've kind of
covered but we can go more detail yeah
yeah see Oh
longtime listener first-time caller but
uh my question for her is uh has she
ever had someone pay for insects and she
was like damn man you're paying me ten
bucks with you
sure happier for free yeah get a couple
times oh yeah oh yeah you're like damn
yeah there was a UH six foot three
professional swimmer and I was just like
what the [ __ ] not gonna name names but
Ryan Lochte and he unfortunately this
guy kind of took advantage of my heart.i
emojis for him and he was like hey can I
take you to lunch like off the clock and
I was like oh no wow and yet to say no
no I stuck to my guns I was like nah
dude like that shut it down that was
just one in particular but I have had I
mean I've had a couple people take their
shirts off and I'm like [ __ ] I'm like I
can't believe it yeah and I'm like we're
guys I'm a bunch of times like I just
[ __ ] enjoy the [ __ ] out of myself and
I was like and I got money to this this
is awesome this is awesome um like if a
girl came up to you and said I'm
thinking about this you know I'm
thinking about getting in a sex work how
do you would you talk her into it or you
talked her out of it and not not judging
your own experience but you know and not
letting whatever you decide to sell her
judge you I'm not judging you by that or
right but would you talk her into it or
talk her out of it um I've had a couple
girls in my you know regular civilian
life
kind of like asked me to help them get
going and stuff and it's turned out for
me to be like quite like a lot of Labor
that I just don't see the point in
anymore so I kind of I'm just like good
luck if you want to do that good luck
right but like I say I'm like I'm you
know I'm special I'm able to
compartmentalize I'm happy and fulfilled
I I don't I'm not I don't know so it's
kind of I guess I would just tell them
it's not for everyone and really you
know consider consider what you're
getting into because it it is a risky
situation it's is it lonely and for me
no but I know for a lot of women at it
is I have I am I'm just a social
butterfly and I have so many friends and
so many people that love and care about
me and I I just
it's not lonely for me but it can be
lonely there are some there are
companions that do a lot of touring so
that's how they make the majority of
their income is by traveling to
different cities and you know posting up
in a nice hotel for a couple days and
seeing clients in that particular city
and I can imagine that probably being
pretty lonely like I don't do that and I
can't do that because of school and
stuff and also I you know I'm a homebody
I like to be at home but I can imagine
that being more lonely but I don't think
like I wouldn't I wouldn't talk anybody
out of it I would just say you know it's
not for everybody but this is my
experience do you have you ever been in
some parties where they got like 4050
ladies there and they got a couple of
you know it's like just a couple of
basketball players types of you know
that's what I always picture I feel like
waterfalls and [ __ ] you know a couple
of brothers hired real real Turtles to
swim around in the pool and you know
everybody's touching each other's ass
and everything um
I know those happen but um I've only
been to like one thing like that I don't
know like I don't know that's not
typically also because I don't party so
I'm not I know you're not in the drug
world is probably totally different yeah
there's girls that are like I party and
party is codeword for all they blow with
you all night I'll do whatever like and
I and I get a spot you know from
potential clients that email me they're
like oh do you party and I'm like nope I
don't so I think a lot I get like kind
of passed over for a lot of that kind of
stuff just because of that fact right
but you also get Pat it probably it
keeps a lot of trouble out of your
universes yes it does yeah this episode
is brought to you by a Squarespace you
ever been to space you ever been asked
where now you can do it all from
websites and online stores to marketing
tools and analytics Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business if
you're doing an old-school method you
know you paying some guy in Germany or
Rome or somewhere to build you a site
you haven't heard from him and
everything and he's laundering your
money and all of that change it up you
have beautiful design
templates right there at Squarespace you
can create a wonderful website domains
websites online stores marketing tools
it's never been easier to sell products
or services online and you can manage
all your products orders and inventory
easily head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com slash Theo
von to save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or a domain that
squarespace.com slash Theo von and if
you want to get right then get
Squarespace I'm trying to think of what
else I want to know I guess well how
about this so like you know I'm a guy in
my life that struggle with you know
commitment a lot and this something I'm
kind of exploring right now I'm own life
you know to be honest with you Allison
and you know I you know a lot of times
when I have like real feelings and stuff
like that you know
I will act I'll find some way like to
either look at pornography or to you
know I would just text sex workers and
just text them you know and be like ah
you know 280 you know what about you
know what if I put on some Cologne and
let's do C or D you don't say oh yeah
yeah oh it's all I'm just total but it
was just like it was ridiculous you know
you could put on a nice hat you know
what I'm saying you know there's a lot
of guys actually third of like but I'm
really good-looking so can you like
anytime someone's told me that I'm like
it's double for you devil for
good-looking dudes I charged double for
that alright but for me it's like I feel
ashamed about about that type of
behavior like thing about pornography I
feel ashamed about I feel ashamed about
any time when I have instead of like
putting my feelings into a relationship
or into a place you know and this could
be my own issue these are my issues but
it's like I feel ya like I'll divert
from something that's real to something
that's more of a fantasy um you know do
you find a lot of your client like you
like there's a lot to unpack there but I
feel like this like I mentioned before
this weird
morale kind of high ground that we have
in this country is really weird and I I
don't understand the shame around sex
because it's the most natural part of
like who we are yeah it's like eating
and sleeping we we need sex like it's
part of in it's an instinctual it's just
a primal thing yeah part of the human
experience so I feel like if you're
doing it in a responsible way I don't I
me personally I don't see anything
anything wrong with it whatsoever as far
as like you know you having like you
said commitment stuff and you'd rather
like like the fantasy is more
interesting to you I mean well somewhere
thing it's just it's easier than going
through and figuring out what my
feelings are to possibly get into a
better place where I could be in actual
relationship you know I think that's
what you feel like you're being
inhibited I just feel it's like man I
get so nervous and stuff about
commitment and so like just internally
somewhere kind of spooked that you know
I will look at things to like engage
like oh I'll look at pornography or I'll
you know flirt with escorts around you
know you know people sending me their
crotch and stuff on snapchat so you know
snap crotch rush people sending some
dudes I mean there's one of our parody
was singing with his dick out and it was
at first he had long hair and I was like
oh who is it and then BAM he turned
around it was a man so snapchat sir it's
really turning to like kind of
chatroulette or what I remember the
chatroulette word love to chat roulette
I thought it was funny you should ever I
was so entertained by that I was so
scared
that's some old-school [ __ ] um I don't
know I guess maybe figure out what makes
you so nervous about things and I mean
yeah maybe you're just an I you're just
not in it point in your life that I
think as far as relationships go and the
right one and the right one for you it
just happens when it happens like
there's no point in like seeking it out
or whatever just like continue to become
the best version of you and you know
that's kind of what I do and
then what happens from there is what's
meant to happen and you just kind of
like let it you know what the universe
take care of it you get a lot of clients
that are married couples or single men
that are like kind of acting outside of
their marriages that are afraid to talk
to their wives do you get just women
clients I've I've never gotten a woman
client but I would I would not be
opposed to that whatsoever I think that
would be a pretty tight experience um
I'd say a good percentage of my clients
are married and it is a discrete thing
and I feel like I give them you know
they've either not become there they've
stopped being intimate for whatever
reason their wife is stop being intimate
with them and they just feel the need
still and they want to do it in the most
responsible way by like doing it in a
transactional way not carrying on an
affair because they really love their
wives and they want to be with their
wives that's our partner that's they're
like partner for life and just because
they've you know kind of like sought
some need outside of that it's I that's
the thing with monogamy to have to like
have one person be everything that you
need your sex partner your you know your
comforter your your you know the love of
your life your chef your like you're the
mother of your children two for one
person to take on all of that is kind of
intense like that's what I'm a little
like monogamy is a little iffy for me
just because of that reason like I feel
like I might be able to make a pierogi
but I can't make you [ __ ] really yeah
like you know it's a lot of it is there
a lot of responsibility that's a lot and
you know as much as I love and you know
I feel like we all have you know we'll
have like multiple loves of our lives
and we'll have multiple partners and
people that like are better suited for
us in different you know days of our
lives and I don't know I feel very just
like fluid about that I guess and I feel
like I've like kind of thing I've kind
of taken care of a specific need that
like a certain person has right and then
they've left feeling relieved and happy
and they know that like you know I'm not
gonna text them and be like you know
when are you gonna leave your wife for
me or whatever because I completely
respect that there you know like I you
know I do service provider
yes that's that's it that's completely
it and I don't you know and I and I say
thank you for doing like I like you're
married thank you for doing this in a
responsible way right thank you for not
like carrying on an emotional affair
with someone who's going to be expecting
you to leave your wife or whatever like
right it's almost I mean it is more I
think if you have to discuss it with a
spouse you you know discussing it like
that
you know if you are gonna you know
participate in those types of behaviors
I mean I still I think for me I
romanticize about you know and I would
like to be in a relationship where you
know everything is right there
you know you got that one-stop shop you
know you got that girl who's you know
making you us you know maybe a nice
gazpacho you know and doing a [ __ ]
there's something in the garage or
something that guys are I feel like
doing Scrabble I feel like that's such a
hard thing to find in one person to like
have the like physical chemistry first
of all like to in order to I've been
always it's been done for a long time
true but like and I know divorce rate is
like over 50% that's it's not perfect
it's monogamy is not perfect and I I've
been when I've been in relationships
even you're in sex work I'm monogamous
with that partner I don't have sex with
anyone like outside of work or that
partner okay um let monogamy scare you
though no not at all not at all I've in
even like in between sex work when I
wasn't doing sex work I've been in
long-term relationships where I was
completely faithful and loyal like I'm a
very loyal person yeah um I don't feel
like I have any like daddy issues or
anything like that but it is difficult
to find someone that you completely like
get along with so well enjoy being
around yeah and then on top of that have
like that fire sex like that but like
you are like addicted to sex with each
other where you just like the cat like
the chemistry is swirling the pheromones
love each other like it's all you know a
lot of people I feel like just get
married because I I don't know if this
is just my observation but they they get
married because it's like oh like you
know it's the easy thing to do and that
person you know they get along generally
but like maybe they don't have like that
like super passionate love life or
whatever I don't know but but they're
better suited in all other ways of life
I don't know I just feel like it I'm
nice to impart
or they can help you get through the
world yeah no I I totally am a hundred
percent all about a partner like I think
that's awesome right but ma I think it
would be quite difficult to find all of
those things and when these days when we
see so many influences that show us that
make us believe you can have everything
it's like maybe we're looking for
something that's not even exactly real
words before we used to be a little bit
more accepting you know if things didn't
work they didn't have this or they then
weren't this yeah and we realized that
we weren't all those things as well or
maybe also thinking that there's
something better out there always yeah
yeah that we're always sold something
better yeah you know it's like even like
you know like celebrities that attach
themselves to different causes like
sometimes it's great and some disco from
cause to cause because it's like the
next better thing Oh
let's switch you over here to you know
people are using you know they're using
a blood rubber over here in these tires
you know so we got to shut this down you
know they're getting these out of you
know this is blood rubber let's get one
more question that came in for two more
that came in for four Allison Nick
please hi Fiona my name is Sarah and I
just had a question for your next
upcoming guest in the line of sex words
how you are able to reconcile the
feelings of like emotional attachment to
fix and just seeing it as work um I
don't mean that in a disrespectful way
I've just always been super emotionally
attached person thank you bye
you know I like that oh yeah a little
more yeah yeah um I I do think that's
actually a really like a big part of it
um because you can do that you said you
can compartmentalize yeah and you're the
rarity though I am I am I think um I
just kind of hold a special place for
those you know like you know I do have
like relationships with my like regular
clients and stuff and like you know I
really enjoy them for who they are but I
I don't have like that super I think a
lot of women just have they carry a lot
of like emotional attachment to sex I
think that's why it's difficult for
women to kind of
you know be [ __ ] because they're like
well what is this like we had sex so
does that mean you know you're gonna be
my boyfriend or I don't know so I I just
I've never really had that I think
that's a really wild idea to even think
that so I'm just I guess I'm in the
minority there but I do have like
rituals in order to like kind of like
you know cut cut the energy cord from
you know after I see a client I'm like
okay cut the energy cord send it back
with love and light like I I do you know
absorb emotional energy so I you know do
what I can to you know cleanse myself of
that and keep myself keep myself healthy
and keep my keep my emotions in check
some I mean some days are better than
others some sometimes it's like man that
didn't sometimes it doesn't feel that
great it's not always you know perfect
but yeah I'm a human I'm not a not a
robot so I guess that's like my best
answer for that but I really appreciate
these questions though ya know I
appreciate the interest I mean I think
it's interesting our Booker gianni we
have a closed-circuit live feed he asked
if your parents knew um yes
uh I've been open somewhat with my
family about it and it's kind of I'm not
the closest with my family so it's
almost like a Don't Ask Don't Tell thing
but you know it they know do you think
if you had a close relation with your
family that you would have even gotten
into something like this do you think
this is that's a good question um I
guess it's hard to know it is hard to
know but I don't know I've kind of
always felt I've always loved sex and
I've always loved will you control it
then yeah it's like you know it's like
um sometimes with comedy it's like I
know if I'm making people laugh like
like when people are laughing they are
it's almost like they're impaired for a
minute like her for a second you know
they're shaking they're making a sound I
mean it's a closed thing you can get to
really shooting somebody you know kind
of you know or electrocuting them right
it's like you know so I know that when
they're it's almost like putting a
little bitty spell on them
you know and I think for me I just felt
probably inside I mean I felt so
uncomfortable that that was the only
moment I could feel comfortable was if
somebody else was you know I knew if
they were like that then I was they
couldn't do anything to me there was
nothing they could though they had no
control in that moment right because
it's involuntary for them to laugh right
so they had no control right it was
completely out of their control because
they were doing something involuntary
and so that was a moment where not like
I had to be so controlling but just I
knew then in that moment that they
weren't going to be able to do something
to make me feel bad or make me feel
scared or harm do you know and so I
relate to that yeah I just wonder
sometimes are not wonder sometimes what
I wonder right now if that's yeah it's
like it's it's like you can control the
situation mm-hmm it's all a very
controlled environment um a lot of like
90% of my job is just talking I think
you like connecting with people yeah
just learning about people I got a lot I
got a lot of free financial advice yeah
bet awesome yeah and I jerk-off
semi-regularly and I'm saying invest in
Amazon actually right now there you go
girl
yeah how about this though do you have
couples that get you a husband and wife
yeah I have had a couple couples let's
rattle through a couple of wild things
that people have had you do um so I had
this couple I drove down Orange County
to see them they white or black or they
were white or orange they were white um
no they were both a little heavyset so I
felt like a [ __ ] Victoria's Secret
model couple little thicker Potamus yeah
boy I liked it they were they they had
their kids off at a baby they like
staying with the grandparents or
something so there was like there was
like you know kids toys and stuff but
you know they did well they had a nice
place um and they were like uh actually
it was it was one of my colleagues that
means to them she's like she's like I've
seen them before and I just I'm not in
the mood to see that I was like okay
[ __ ] it I'll do it
so they were like partying they're like
yeah this is like our special tree
they're doing some cocaine they were
doing some blow they were you know what
we use were they listening to
I think just like top 40 yeah they were
like and also the thing is a bit they
were only like three years older than me
and I felt like they were 15 years older
than me they were like got a sunburn and
tits yeah yeah it was a inch though the
wife was wearing like you know lingerie
and then he was like oh man this is so
exciting and um she basically was like I
just she's like I don't really like
sucking his dick so if you could suck
his dick she was like cheering me on and
it was like it was that was very
challenging because I don't know if you
know what below does to a penis but it's
not a fun situation that's at
Punxsutawney Phil boy I just get into
this like meditative like oh you're
gonna come you're gonna come you're
gonna come like I like I've all other
thoughts kind of flat on my head you
only got to punch somebody in the
[ __ ] to come if they're cocaine
you got a really it was exhausting and
and he you know she was like kind of
like then she had me come outside and we
like smoked a cigarette together um and
she was like you know I just I know that
I just wanted him to have like a fun
time because I know like you know I
don't want him to like cheat on me so I
figure if we do this together then it's
it's all good and then I found out later
from my girlfriend that the guy hits her
up to see her alone all the time so I'm
like oh god that was like a completely
disingenuous situation but um yeah and
actually that girlfriend of mine she
told me about a situation that I was
just so horrified by hearing she went
and saw a married couple that were in
their mid 80s oh yeah boy and that's at
least 84 let's remember that geriatric
and she told me that the room the hotel
room smelled like a turns out like a
nursing home and I was just like girl I
couldn't do it I think there's a nursery
there are some situations where I'm like
I could not and she was like I feel so
desensitized after that she said she
went down on the lady Wow
I was like I had a newfound respect for
that chick I really did I was like that
Barbara Bush daddy you know her all you
did it dad he said it was like she
lowers beans there's an hour's - I mean
that goes she walked away from that one
like you know
8,000 like she got a lot from that
because she's you know she has a high
she's a high rate she walked away with a
lot of money but I'm like I don't even
think I could do that or though I don't
know there's a price for everything but
[ __ ] have you ever been surprised like a
celebrity hired you you went over there
and it was a celebrity um yes and is
that kind of scary or um no I just I
really just try to maintain my
professionalism always yeah and my
discretion like I you know I see clients
out like you know I've been out I feel
like I can't go to steak houses in
Beverly Hills at all I just can't go so
Mastro's is a bad always see yeah like
I'm either with a client or I see a
client why just you know we're just it's
a very discrete like it's like a secret
it's like a cute secret and is it's like
do you ever act like do you have a
finishing move if you're finishing off a
client like you're trying to get
somebody to bust out or whatever what is
my foot uh I bust out like if it's if
it's getting I had this client that I
saw all the time and I think he had a
cocaine problem but he was uh I
tolerated him because he gave me way
more than my rate and you know it was
worth it to me I would have to bring
baby oil and just like oil up my tits
oil up their dick you can't put a condom
on after that because oil will break
through the latex so it's kind of all
just like hands and tits and like ball
rubbing and that's usually my finisher
if if all else fails if the golden [ __ ]
can't do it then it happened which isn't
often then it's the oil the kind of
things along ND of a regular [ __ ] or
what is that like do I have a regular
[ __ ] yeah I I love my [ __ ] I think my
[ __ ] is pretty special okay
I have a special [ __ ] yeah yeah I call
it a princess [ __ ] okay cuz I don't
like like I tell people I'm like I can
only do like a certain amount of like
actual intercourse before it starts
getting a little out cheese for me okay
and what about everybody these days
everybody's in the bud activity you said
earlier that's not one of your things no
no I mean what is something wild that
somebody's requested that you've had to
be like none um
well I did something pretty wild that I
would never do again that wasn't that
was completely surprised
like I this gentleman walked in with
kind of like a toiletries bag I guess
and um that's an overnight kid I this is
something that I was like I had to take
a couple days off after this mm-hmm um
he walked in and he he just had like a
old Purdy vibe which I'm like I can
handle it it's fine I counted the money
first it's all good so then he's like
you know it seems like a regular session
and then uh listen he's like hey um can
we play with toys and I was like I don't
have any toys like what do you mean he's
like oh no I brought some he pulls out I
cannot believe I'm saying this out loud
but he pulls out this thing with a
wooden handle oh yeah you know on the
end of it is three lump like baseball
sized metal balls all kind of like
linked together with a wooden handle
okay and then he pulls out baby lotion
oh yeah like a really pad like the pink
Johnson in the gladiator hitter man like
not roar but not lube or anything oh
yeah and he asked me to put that into
his butt mm-hmm and I did it just
because it was in the moment and how do
you think this thing yeah how big was it
like I feel like how long would you hold
it up in the air for your arm we get
tired you think um I mean I don't know
I'm in pretty good shape so I don't I
could probably hold it for a while but I
felt like I was like how long like two
hours or like 30 seconds high 30 seconds
oh wow it was heavy it was a heavy duty
thing like the handle was wooden the the
balls were metal like he squirts a bunch
of [ __ ] baby lotion on it and I felt
like I was plunging a toilet like it was
[ __ ] up it was so [ __ ] up I was like
that is the most fucked-up thing that
I've ever had to do and what was he
doing this whole time was he reading was
the owner it was I'm just enjoying he
was just into it and I was like [ __ ] and
what is he touching his wiener some
during I think he wanted yeah yeah and
then he contacted me again later and I
I told them that it was super [ __ ] up
than he did not I was like you should
never do that to people ever so I was
[ __ ] with him do that to you yes I
was like I mean obviously like nothing
was happening to me but I was like the
whole experience of it I was like what
in the actual [ __ ] is happening right
now that's probably one of the worst
probably the worst like I just was a
little that was too much
yeah I had to take a couple days off
after that I was like no no no yeah
that's a lot it was a lot that's the
dark arts that I would say is the dark
arts for sure that was I mean everyone
likes their own thing you know people
are kinky whatever but for me
specifically and that's what I love also
about sex work is it's fully anything I
do is in my control your control I say
yes and no I control it I'm like nope
I'm not into that sorry like no I'm not
into kink that or kink this or whatever
I don't do that just like you know I
don't do but stuff like whatever like I
can make my own rules and nobody can say
[ __ ] to me about them because it's my
own [ __ ] body and it's my rules there
you go that's it we have a gift for you
and this is from one of our sponsors
it's from Ridge they make some really
cool stuff yeah and you can open it up
okay and it's a really yeah oh my god
cool I'll bring this to work just
kidding you go oh yeah that's a plan I
thought I'd be a good plan yeah and it's
a nice knife they make a lot of really
cool stuff that make the wallet that I
have and they make a lot of great items
amazing so let me see it so you can
protect yourself thank you just like
push that part down okay you can close
that part but yeah this is a beautiful
knife is a high-end fancy knife and you
can get these at I think Ridge wallet
calm
/ - Theo and they have a link on there
and you can get 10% off and think we'll
put the link up and we'll put it below
in the in the elements it's a nice knife
though that's very nice thank you have
you ever read a knife someone no no I've
never been in like a particularly
dangerous situation but - one time I got
completely ripped off but really and
that life scared me because I was like
this guy's probably a [ __ ] psycho but
other than that I don't feel like I've
been in any I mean love thank God
like I you know I realize what I do is
you know risky but I have put a lot of
things in place in order to keep myself
safe do you feel like over time though
saved like these laws where you can't
advertise on these sites eventually
it'll keep women from doing it at all do
you see that that long term it could be
helpful um it's the oldest profession in
the world it's never gonna go away
they're never there you go
Alison you know you're a sex worker and
you're a charming lady and sex worker
you I remember you saying you said to me
whenever we spoke on the phone you said
sex worker mhm and other terms oh yes we
say sex worker because it humanizes us
because we are workers were legitimate
workers I don't like I really don't like
obviously prostitute is like a legal
term hooker [ __ ] hoe whatever those
words dehumanize us like they people are
just like oh that you know she doesn't
matter she's a hooker she's not a real
person I wanted like I want people to
humanize us we're normal people everyone
I know is educate like every girl that I
know that does this is educated
well-traveled emotionally healthy
wonderful beautiful people artists like
happy people like we enjoy what we do
like just let us work and let us let us
work and like be safe what if people
were like oh she got that party kitty is
that an okay time yeah that's an okay
time party kitty sure
I'm just trying to think of something
that you know that's still you know
obtuse but it's also kind of fun yeah no
I think escort companion those are all
acceptable terms like derogatory terms
like hooker ho you know all that is it
just um it's equivalent to you know
derogatory terms about trans people or
people of color like it's and she got
that secret slick slick that's what some
people could say mmm-hmm okay sorry I'm
losing mine here um but awesome thanks
so much for being here with us today and
we really appreciate I think yeah
definitely educational for me you know
to see another side of it where somebody
that's not a that hasn't been sex
trafficked
a lot of people that are sex trafficked
in your work never never yeah I've never
seen I don't know no never I I really
haven't yeah and maybe it's just it's a
world issue and America is just trying
to be an example you know that's one of
the things that I think America
struggles with a lot is well how do we
you know be an example right and I
honestly think this bill was just a very
sneaky way of kind of taking away our
freedom of speech fine
oh I see that all the time man percent
tech is the new fossil fuels dude if you
don't think that you know these
companies are the new oil companies then
then you're wrong broadband is gonna
become real estate it's all I mean I
believe in some of these things I'm
saying I just we'll discuss it another
time
Alison thanks so much for being here
with us today we really appreciate thank
you for having me yep and we're gonna
pay Alison actually for being here today
no yeah it's work you know no we
consider this yeah to consider this your
time and so we will pay you for that and
thank you so much
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my my I can feel it enough
thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]